doors
massages before the big day
how beautiful
Northwest surprises Kim Kardashian with
a little pre-met Gala pampering I don't
know what's going to top that the
reality star arrived in New York City on
Sunday ahead of Fashion's biggest night
with North and her cousin Kourtney
Kardashian's daughter Penelope Disick in
tow so that's really meaningful to me
and Kim she shared this clip of her
hotel room covered in candles white rose
petals and silver balloons reading Carl
Lagerfeld Met Gala
my gosh Carl Lagerfeld Met Gala
North
massages before the big day
a beautiful the kkw beauty founder
gushed over the whole thing writing how
sweet is North for surprising me tonight
with this for us to relax before the met
thank you the 2023 Met Gala takes place
Monday night in NYC the theme this year
is Carl Lagerfeld a line of beauty and
celebrates the full work and life of the
late designer despite reports that none
of the Kardashian Jenners were invited
to this year's event Kim made it clear
that she will be there last week she
shared this selfie with the late
designer's Cat writing that she spent
some time at Carl's office to get a
little inspiration for the event I know
this is all about fashion but I just
think that you still got to be yourself
and I definitely have a sexy side I have
my mom's side Penelope's dad Scott
Disick was spotted out in New York as
was Kim's sister Kendall Jenner who was
seen over the weekend with her rumored
new bow Bad Bunny give the fans exactly
what they wanted from us the dress code
this year is in honor of Carl and Kim
she's been known to pull out all the
stops yeah Bible it's a great look Kim
made her Met Gala debut in 2013 pregnant
with her first child North rocking a
custom Givenchy dress in 2014 she posed
with her now ex Kanye West in Lon Von in
2015 it was all about Roberto Cavalli
one year later she was sparkling in
balmond and in 2017 she stunned in this
white Vivian Westwood she was the golden
girl at the 2018 Met Gala in Versace and
put her curves on display in this mugler
number in 2019. this is like beyond what
I ever
thought Couture was of course no one can
forget her 2021 all black Balenciaga
look and last year she made headlines
for slipping into Marilyn Monroe's happy
birthday dress this is Marilyn Monroe's
dress
16 pounds
down today to be able to fit this this
will Mark Kim's 10th Met Gala and one
thing's for sure we can't wait to see
what she does next
foreign